if you were given the opportunity to sit
with a group of brand-new actors let's
suppose it's a roundtable and they asked
your advice on casting directors what
would you tell them and this is the
steep Tom show this is your forum Wow in
what in what sense and what Oh suppose
you've been asked to come to a college
or something a lecture and they want to
know everything there is to know about
casting directors what should you say
how I approach it should you bring them
flowers oh okay oh yeah all that stuff
first of all ditch the perfume and the
Cologne
luckily years ago that happened and and
because casting directors were
complaining because people were bathing
and perfume and cologne and coming into
the room and and after you know a bunch
of people paraded in and out it was just
overwhelming and a lot of people have
allergies to that so that that's the
first thing and don't you know just take
shower with soap and don't put anything
on after that it's it's much nicer for
everybody involved what else
sending a gift to a casting director
after you've booked something oh that's
I generally don't do that I'll pick up
the phone or drop by the office if
that's an office where I can do that and
we have that kind of relationship and
and thank them and let them know how
grateful I am for the opportunity that
that they gave me by casting me in this
project and it it was wonderful and I
had the time of my life I'll do that I
have given gifts to casting directors
just because in my mind the the
opportunity that I had because of them
was so monumental and career changing
that I think it was it just deserved
more than a cordial thank you but
their job is to shine for the production
company they want to bring in the best
actors they possibly can and when
they've done that and everything goes
smoothly and the director and the crew
and the production company in the studio
or are so happy with the way things
turned out on the shoot that you know
that's a great reward for a casting
office for everybody in the casting
office and I know everybody does their
job and and I don't think we all have to
you know constantly thank one another
for it and I think that you know sort of
falls into the area of trying too hard
again they know who you are they they
bring you in because they they know who
you are and they want to see you you
don't have to thank them for it that's
their job and I and I don't mean to say
that casting should be thankless there
there's a great documentary that was
released a couple of months ago called
casting by did you did you happen to see
it yeah it's wonderful that focused on a
particular casting director and her
efforts to to have that part of the film
process or the television process
recognized by the awards shows anyway
I'm kind of going a little far afield
there it's a wonderful documentary if
you can ever see if you ever have a
chance to see casting by don't miss it
it's wonderful it'll give you a whole
new perspective on that particular part
of the industry what else
dudes and don'ts for casting directors
that's kind of what we're talking about
here etiquette when you walk in the room
how conversational should you be okay
this is my personal etiquette I don't
reach out and shake hands but I don't
touch anybody unless they offer first
they're you know people are petri dishes
and I don't really want to touch them
and I don't think they want to touch me
but if somebody extends their hand to me
certainly I'll extend my back props
don't bring props into an audition that
just it's sort of desperate and you
don't need them everybody has an
imagination and they can use them and
you don't need to do that don't ever
touch a casting director as part of a
scene a fantasy or supposed to be
strangling someone they're not the
person you want to actually put your
hands around their neck don't do that um
feedback do you want to harangue your
agent about feedback can you call the
casting office and please get feedback
please I want to hear feedback on my
audition how did I do
how did I do the feedback is rather not
you booked the job and that is not
necessarily negative feedback the thing
that mode the the most valuable thing
that ever happened to me in this
business was being able to sit in on a
casting session on their side of the on
their side of the room to see what
happened it was actually a commercial
casting session for a client that I have
now an ongoing client that I have now
99.9 percent of the time the decision
not to hire an actor has nothing to do
with the actor nothing particularly in
commercials it has to do with issues of
diversity it has to do with height or
color of hair mixing and matching
different actors to achieve the goal of
the client that must be serve I mean
those things must be served before
anything else these decisions don't have
anything to do with the actor
necessarily most of the time they don't
have anything to do with it and should
never be taken personally ever it's hard
to understand that unless you do get
that opportunity to sit in on a casting
session on the casting director side and
to hear the conversations after you
after the actors have left the room to
hear what they actually talk about it's
not them it's not me it's it's something
else so you know just go in the room and
bring bring it just bring it bring your
a-game and leave quickly leave quickly
why I would much rather there have been
times when I've stayed in the room a
little bit too long and been a little
too chatty and and I I thought well you
know the longer I stay in here the the
more they're gonna get to know who the
real me is and they're not gonna be able
to resist me and know I would now I
would much rather have them want me to
come back in the room I want to I want
to leave them wanting a little bit more
so I go in I do my work I say thank you
and I leave quickly and I close the door
behind me and if they want me to come
back before I'm in the car they'll come
and get me that actually happened once I
was auditioning for a crime drama set in
New York I won't tell you which one it
was sure the audition was like 2 or 3
days after 9/11 and
I walked in the room and I was
introduced and somebody said how you
doing and I said well I picked a hell of
a time to quit smoking and you could
have heard a pin drop just crickets and
somebody I don't know who it was
but one of the producers or somebody in
the room this was a producer session
somebody said the hell do you think you
are don't you know what what happened
two days ago and I looked up and I said
hold it who said that which one of you
said that and nobody nobody would admit
to it I said you know what screw you all
because everybody is dealing with this
horrific thing and the best way they
knew how
and you know I chose to put a light
touch on it when I came in the room here
and how dare you get on your high horse
and tell anybody else how they should
feel about this you know have a great
shoot screw you I didn't say screw you
but I walked out the door I said eff you
walked out the door walked out the door
didn't read I was furious and before I
got to my car somebody came running
after me and told me to come back and I
went back in the room and they said you
know what that's kind of what we're
looking for in this character and and
we'd like to offer you the job
that's what happened I don't recommend
that as a you know as a rule I in fact I
don't recommend it at all but it was
just one of those things that happened
to work at the time and
you